[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARRY KASPAROV: Check.
Chess is a game of
unlimited beauty.
But it's not just
checks and attacks.
You have to be creative.
I'm here to share with you my
knowledge of the game of chess.
But I'm trying to come up with
the comprehensive picture that
will be helpful for you
to become a better chess
player, and even a
better decision maker.
Let's cover it.
king g5, king c2, king f6, king
b3, king b7, king c4, king d6,
king b5, king c7, king a6.
Boom.
White lost, yes?
Queen takes the knight at
5, and it's a double attack.
Skewer and attraction,
and it's mate.
What an amazing mate.
How can we prevent this
rook from stopping our pawn?
Let's pause, stop
the video, and think.
Okay.
You have time to find
this winning combination.
Did you see that?
Your bishop was hanging--
Man: There, yeah.
--but then you have now c5.
Ah, no, I didn't
see that line.
That's interesting.
So you attack my bishop,
then you protect your bishop.
Right.
So let's go back and see
whether we can improve,
and what's the
next logical moves?
It's about coming
up with new ideas,
challenging your own excellence.
Find your mistakes.
Next time, you
have to be better.
I've been thinking about a
few ideas that I never used.
The one I want to show--
it's another sacrifice.
I like sacrifices.
And it's one of my
favorite openings,
so just let's have a look.
We cannot waste time.
Time is precious.
If you don't feel that
the game can unleash
your creative
potential, then you're
already on the losing side.
It's not about
winning or losing.
But of course, at
the end of the day,
it's about winning or losing.
I'm Garry Kasparov, and
this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]